Stars I'm Anna Vance say we expect
preview access to Super Nintendo World
We have tons of hidden details tons of
Easter eggs but first let's get
somewhere a little more quiet
hey
yo I lost my mustache in their summer oh
well anyway as I was saying I visited
Super Nintendo World in Universal
Studios Hollywood now officially open to
the public and let me tell you there are
so many really cute specific details in
this place that you're not going to find
in any other video and I was able to
chat with Abby finnon the show producer
at Universal creative and get some
inside info on what to look out for so
let's dive into all the love that went
into this place and I'm saving my
absolute favorite detail that most
people will never see for last so stick
around also I passed by Shakira
so believe it or not you can learn some
things about what the park is going to
be like before you even go in the colors
of the word world exactly match the ones
of Super Mario 3D World which was the
very first Mario game to use that exact
color combination and these blocks
featured behind the logo are also from
that game so before we even enter we can
guess that it's mostly going to be based
on Super Mario 3D World and this holds
true but we'll get back to that real
quick
[Music]
these tracks and all the other ones we
use on new rockstars are from Persona
music a new massive music licensing
space built by creators for creators
Persona music offers unlimited copyright
cleared music for your videos on all
platforms under a single subscription
license their Library features music
from Marvel and Disney trailers Emmy
award-winning soundtracks and hundreds
of hit TV shows if you're a Creator
getting your content flag for copyright
issues keeps people from seeing what
you've made and keeps you from making
money off of it Persona music makes your
life so much easier Persona integrates
with YouTube's Content ID fingerprinting
system to detect and clear claims within
minutes just pop your channel ID and
social URLs in your user dashboard and
boom you're whitelisted all videos
published during your presona
subscription will be cleared from
Content ID claims forever to get started
with Persona music just head to
app.personamusic.io or click the link in
the description go to the pricing page
choose your plan sign up and apply code
of rockstars25 at checkout to get a 25
discount and one free month of persona
music to enter the land you go through a
giant pipe with multi-colored lights
that give the same atmosphere as that
place between pipes that Mario and Luigi
travel through and what we've seen of
the Super Mario Brothers movie we come
out of the other side and are hit
straight away with the Nostalgia feels
as we step into the Super Mario 64
version of Peach's castle it has the
checkered floor the sun detailing on the
ground and even the sky ceiling detail
above that where in the game you would
look up to be transported to the Tower
of the Wing Cap look left and right and
you can see two paintings one inspired
by the Bob on Battlefield level of the
game and the other inspired by tiny huge
island these paintings transform into
different pictures using the same
Rippling effect that happens when Mario
jumps into the paintings in the game and
the pictures they train transform into
our Peach with the golden mushroom and
Bowser Jr lurking off to the side and
Bowser Jr stealing the golden mushroom
and this is our initial introduction to
the overarching plot of this Park's
story if you go the route of getting the
power-up bands playing the games to get
the keys and then fighting Bowser Jr but
we'll put a bookmark in that and get
back to it later so remember how I was
saying that the majority of this world
would be influenced by Super Mario 3D
World so why would the first thing we
step into be Super Mario 64 themed I
think this is to purposefully show the
transition and evolution of the universe
fans who grew up playing the first games
are touched to see a sight they know and
love and then get to physically step
into the beautiful future of the series
and really feel the Magnificent scale of
its growth all while hearing the
familiar Melodies that have stayed
consistent throughout the years but
don't worry we'll have a whole section
dedicated to the music of the park so
you step into the mainland and you truly
feel like you have been transported into
the world they've done an amazing job
with the immersion aspect the thwomp
creates a little dust cloud when it hits
the ground the flower is planted by
Peach's castle on gazebo are the same
ones from Super Mario 3D World things
that fully could have gone overlooked
have been transformed into designs
straight out of the game I'm talking
arrows I'm talking lamps I'm talking
doors the freaking bathrooms have
underwater murals play the underwater
theme and smell like the ocean they
didn't have to but they did I appreciate
that the main centerpiece of the world
is styled after Mount Bean Pole or world
one three from you guessed it Super
Mario 3D World the clouds at the top are
a really nice detail there the lamps
that they feature actually match up
pretty well with the world map were
shown in the Super Mario Brothers movie
trailer there's Peach's castle a desert
land and Iceland and Bowser's Castle
possibly representing the dark land with
Yoshi's Island featured inside the
attraction there's no Donkey Kong
Country yet but a Donkey Kong Country
expansion of the park is coming to Japan
in 2024 and will be coming to the states
sometime after that I tried to confirm
if this park would be getting an
expansion with Miss fitted but she was
keeping her lips sealed tight
so we'll have to wait and see but
looking at each of these lands more
closely we can figure out what exact
games they're based on the desert land
is based on world 2 from Super Mario 3D
World which we can tell from the design
on the walls and the fact that this is
the only game to have pyramids with the
tops cut off like that looking at the
Iceland the trees ground in mountains
all appear to be from the Frosted
Glacier World from new Super Mario Bros
U Deluxe Bowser's Castle is based mostly
on the Mario Kart 8 model which makes
sense considering it houses the Mario
Kart ride but uses a giant Bowser head
entryway that's seen in a lot of the
games but most closely resembles the one
in Mario Kart Wii or Super Mario 3D Land
the Yoshi's Island section is most
definitely based on new Yoshi's Island
seen by the unique Yoshi coins and Odes
to several of the levels via pink
flowers gem filled caves and beanstalks
among other things and finally looking
at Peach's castle this one kind of
confuses me on how much it doesn't
perfectly match any of the games exactly
it's kind of close to the one in Odyssey
which would make sense as that's the
closest match in the new movie but uses
the Super Mario 64 stained glass design
which the movie didn't an enigma but
beautiful nonetheless some of the other
cute features in the mainland are the
giant mushroom
umbrellas Pavilions well I don't know
what to call them we'll just say the
giant mushrooms with the little mushroom
seats under them these are also featured
in the new movies trailer but the Toads
use the smaller mushrooms as tables
instead of seats in that there are also
binoculars from Super Mario Odyssey that
you can look through and see different
fun AR details depending on the time of
day like mystery doors blue coins and
fireworks at night and you can even zoom
in on certain places to find Easter eggs
like the comet observatory with Rosalina
malumas from Super Mario Galaxy or even
Pikmin if you can't find the Pikmin
through the binoculars though don't
worry these little guys can be spotted
around the park too the mini games you
play to unlock keys are also based on
various levels and enemies in Super
Mario 3D World like the Rolling Hills
and the Sleepy extra long piranha
creepers also on the topic of mini games
and hidden details there are four hard
to spot M sensors scattered around the
park where if you you activate them with
a power band and 8-bit Mario character
will light up just in case you need an
extra dash of old school among all these
new age references one of the main
attractions at the park is Toadstool
Cafe which is built to look like a toad
house from Super Mario 3D World both
inside and out step inside and you'll
notice both a physical small and big
present hanging from the ceiling and
virtual ones you can access with your
power up band which are references to
the power ups you can get from Toad
Houses in the game but that's not all
the floors Windows pillars and dining
area walls are all identical to the game
too they also pulled references from the
Toad Houses in new Super Mario Bros U as
you can see from the first room's walls
and you get hints of it in the design of
the dining area ceiling as well the next
room you walk into introduces us to Chef
toad which heartbreakingly indicates to
me that Tasty's time in the Mario
universe is up where is she Nintendo is
she in one of those cans back there be
honest actually speaking of what is Chef
toad working with back there in the
background we can see some mushrooms
some apple a little canned fruit salad
and he's got a checklist that I almost
thought might say something in cursive
when you flip the image but it's the
same thing on the clipboard at the park
in Japan so it is probably just
scribbles anyway I may have cried over
my burger at the thought of losing tasty
but I have to admit this is pretty dang
cute but the fun don't stop there
because the rest of this place is
equally Charming the counter where you
order is set up like a traditional game
shop and they offer a variety of cute
foods with their own little details like
the Superstar lemon squash drink with
little mango stars in it and the
mountain Bean pull cake which is made to
look like Mount Bean pole with the flag
and all I also just want to point out
how the trash and recycling bins how
these little banana peels on them which
just makes me feel all warm and fuzzy in
the dining room you can see various
sites in the windows scattered around
most of the time you're watching cute
little toads doing their cute little
toad thing and also there are those same
flowers from around the park again but
if you wait long enough you'll get to
see a storm coming in and a full-on
Bowser Airship attack I'll take fries at
the side of impending doom please thank
you and then in the back window you can
see into the kitchen where the toads are
preparing all the food now I gotta say
the more I look at their kitchen the
more questions I have I see what might
be a cute little nod to the radishes in
Super Mario Bros 2 up front which is
nice and then there's a sign in the back
saying that bananas plus an apple does
not equal a turnip
yeah okay I might start seeing some
credentials from these toads actually
but okay what's what's in the back here
you got some cookbooks coins which seem
like a weird thing to have in the
kitchen what looks like coins from a
completely different game and what are
the pictures on these cans you can't
tell me that was not a cartoon dog we
have gotta go so normally now would be
the time that I talk about the main ride
of the park Mario Kart Bowser's
challenge but let me tell you there were
so many details both on the ride and in
the queue for this ride that I need to
make it its own video I know I know but
like just to give you a taste in one of
the many many rooms I saw a 75 book
titles that yes will be listed in that
second video which will probably be the
same length as this video but they're
worth it we were even given the heads up
to keep an eye out for them
the books in Bowser's study okay some
great ones in there but it's too much
for this video so let's jump over to
where you end up at the end of the ride
the one up Factory this store is so cute
and this style definitely reminds me of
Super Mario Galaxy's toy time Galaxy or
rolling Gizmo Galaxy however the details
like the fans arrows and meters are all
incredibly similar to Mario Party 9's ba
bomb Factory overall just a lovely Feast
for the eyes so now it is time to remove
the Bowser Jr bookmark I put in at the
beginning of the video because I feel
like we're ready starting with the
outside his Fortress Is sat next to his
dad's and this heartwarmingly a much
smaller castle with an unbeaten flag on
the top once you get the three keys
necessary to unlock the giant padlock
you get a glimpse of a hideaway straight
out of a destructive toddler's dream
there's graffiti everywhere and if
you'll remember the paintings when you
first entered you'll note that Bowser Jr
has a paintbrush now this paintbrush was
first introduced to him which is a nice
way to say that he stole it in Super
Mario Sunshine where he used it to
Graffiti the city now it's not the same
pain brush since that one had Professor
egad's logo on it and last we saw was no
longer in Bowser Jr's possession but
more than likely is the one he has in
Super Mario 3D World Bowser's Fury
however I do believe all this graffiti
in his Hideaway is still a Super Mario
Sunshine reference and in Japan the M
marking from the game is even at the
entrance but it's been emitted from this
version for some reason but the graffiti
is delightfully childish and the details
in the paintings like the apple juice
he's drinking in one of them remind us
that this tiny Tyrant is still just a
toddler which makes his mischievous
nature oddly lovable we get a better
sense of this mixture of innocence and
destructiveness in the Next Room as we
see his horde of weapons like the
paintbrush Koopa broom Hammer bro helmet
and Hammer poison shroom spikeball Mecca
Koopa and Goomba shoe there's also a
magic wand among these weapons which
from the colors looks to be Wendy's wand
alongside his blocks his building blocks
so cute his Junior clown car is also
being stored here which we can tell
isn't the original clown car due to the
smaller smile and round her eyes Bowser
Jr shadow Showdown is all about trying
to get back the golden mushroom that he
stole from Princess Peach and when you
do you're rewarded with a letter of
gratitude from The Princess herself so
one major overlooked thing that could
really a lot to the ad
s traditional versions of songs from
through
out the place subtly in the background
of all the areas of the park here are
some of the ones I heard during my visit
but keep in mind that each area can have
a variety of tracks that cycle through
so this is just what happened to be
playing when I was in any given area the
entrance to the park is an original
composition unique to Super Nintendo
world that has a bit of Gusty garden
galaxy from Super Mario Galaxy in it
giving it a feeling of Adventure and
wonder when you enter the pipe at the
entrance the warp pipe sound plays
followed by athletic theme from Super
Mario Brothers 3. in Peach's castle you
appropriately hear the song inside the
castle walls from Super Mario 64. and
upon leaving the castle and stepping
into the mainland you are greeted with
the famous Overworld theme from Super
Mario Brothers some other themes that
you'll hear walking around the main area
include super Bell Hill and world one
from Super Mario 3D World many of the
songs you hear are directly tied to the
area you're in so in the underground
themed areas you'll likely hear the
Super Mario Brothers underground theme
or the Super Mario 3D land castle theme
along with a ton of Mario Kart 8 songs
in Bowser's Castle you might hear flower
garden from Yoshi's Island while in the
she's New Island part of the queue or
common Observatory 3 from Super Mario
Galaxy while dining at Toadstool Cafe
like I said there are so many more songs
besides these so be sure to keep your
ears open when you visit and now you
made it this far it is time for my
absolute favorite detail in all of Super
Nintendo World something that most
people will never see when they visit
something that is so minute and
overlooked that it will never fully get
the appreciation it deserves something
you can't even begin to imagine are you
ready the wet floor sign is a banana
peel
so that is every detail you could
possibly hope for at Super Nintendo
World Sun spouses Castle which will be
its own video so be on the lookout for
that and a huge thanks to Universal for
allowing us this exclusive access this
is our first time covering a theme park
on new rockstars so if you'd be
interested in more theme park coverage
leave a comment below until then you can
follow me on Twitter at it'sanna vanston
and follow And subscribe to new
rockstars at new rockstars for more
breakdowns of everything you love
[Music]
thank you